and russian president vladimir putin has
a new message of defiance overnight
putin used an annual moscow parade held
to mark victory in world war ii as an
occasion to justify the invasion with
false claims and propaganda he blamed
ukraine and the west and took no
responsibility for the atrocities
allegedly committed on his orders
deborah patta is in ukraine for us with
what putin had to say deborah quite a
speech good morning
good morning putin used the defeat of
nazi germany to defend his war in
ukraine despite speculation there was no
victory declaration and no hint of a
stronger push on the battlefield
marching in moscow's red square a show
of putin's power
[Music]
today he said you are defending what
your grandfather's fought for
he used the day to blame nato expansion
for his war and bolster the lie he is
denuzifying ukraine
the danger grew every day he said russia
made a preemptive move against
aggression
in russia losses are touted as victories
allegations of atrocities dismissed as a
hoax
kremlin controlled media targeting even
the very young but in ukraine putin's
war is seen as a series of brutal
attacks and strategic blunders russian
troops stand accused of nearly ten
thousand war crimes
and vladimir zelinski put a new spin on
that old idiom reigning on your parade
very soon there will be two victory days
in ukraine he said and someone won't
have any we won then we will win now
ukraine's resistance is the inspiring
story of this awful war
returning to kyiv acting u.s ambassador
christina kavin summed it up succinctly
who across the entire country including
those in the east of ukraine
refused to bend to his will
and told the russians go f yourself
russia may have put on an impeccable
parade but that military precision has
not been mirrored on the battlefield
there is a very muted commemoration of
victory day here in ukraine
understandably people are consumed by
the war they are fighting right here
right now eureka
patta thank you